let's bring in Step bass and whose line
for us in Amsterdam hello there Step
you've been tracking reaction of this
announcement from EU countries how are
they responding to what uh Putin's had
to say
well I would say the response is a mix
between some concern but also Defiance
here in the European capitals this
address by Putin was already highly
anticipated and I don't think there was
much of a surprise here the boulders
response so far I have to say it's
coming from the Dutch prime minister
Mark Rutter who has so said that there
is a sign of panic from the side of
Vladimir Putin that he has to announce
this mobilization and he also said that
the nuclear threat coming from the
Russian president leaves him cold and he
actually said it leaves him Siberian
cold and that's a saying here in Dutch
that he is using but he also says we
shouldn't be retracting we have to still
support Ukraine because a lot of things
are still moving but a little bit more
concern coming from the German Capital
Robert Harback the vice Chancellor
Saturday this is a sign of further
escalation by Russia and also it's a
wrong step and he says this definitely
needs a political response as well and
this is going to be interesting what
will the EU going to do what will be the
further steps they have already of
course implemented uh very significant
sanctions so what is left there to do so
that's something that we need to look
out for in the next hours or so and then
also the Czech prime minister has
responded he also said this is a sign
that Russia is the sole aggressor so
these are the the responses so far I
have to say it's not a huge response and
also this nuclear threat I saw a much
more concern for example last February
when the war started when The Invasion
started it was real concern among people
here in Europe about this nuclear threat
the possible nuclear war it has died
down since the War developed maybe it's
now a moment that it comes back this
fear but this uh it has no science
whatsoever at the moment here in
Amsterdam for example Steph thank you
very much for those enzymes step Vass
and live for us in Amsterdam Let's cross
to London now where Sonia Gallego is
standing by for us Sonia this marks yet
another challenge for the new prime
minister what's been the reaction in the
UK to Putin's mobilization of troops
well Emily is to be expected as the UK
has put itself forward as one of
Ukraine's biggest cheerleaders as it
were a continuation from the former
prime minister Boris Johnson's very
public show of support for Ukraine is
that certainly the defense minister has
said in a statement today that it is in
effect an admission that The Invasion
his invasion uh Vladimir Putin's is
failing and they're focusing on the fact
that it is this admission that is
forcing uh Putin to in effect undermine
his own message that this is a special
operation that it's not having any
effect on Russia but certainly this is
very much uh top of the agenda for the
new prime minister Liz truss Liz truss
who was foreign minister of course
helped in her role at the time to secure
more military equipment for you crane as
well there was a 2.8 billion dollar
package that was secured for Ukraine in
the fight against Russia as well as a
promise to train up to 10 000 Ukrainian
soldiers or military personnel over the
course of three months at a at a British
base but yes of course this is very much
a very a very important part of Liz
truss's agenda as it were yes there are
other issues going on in the UK but of
course the war that is in Ukraine is of
course under underlining these issues as
well with the energy crisis uh cost of
living crisis as well the costs that
have been having ramifications in the UK
as well so to tackle this and to be seen
to be a strong force in a post-brexit
country is really very important for the
prime minister to project that the UK is
firmly on the side of Ukraine and any
show of weakness that is being uh is
really put out by uh Putin really has to
be counted and the military intelligence
is also saying that this is really going
to be an undermining of his own message
to his own people and I think that's
where they're going to be concentrating
on right now that in a sense Putin what
he is doing here is admitting a failure
in his own War Sonia thanks for breaking
all down for us Sonia Gallego live for
us in London thank you
for those getting the call up are
expected to have military experience at
the beginning of the year Russia had
about 900 000 active troops but last
month President Putin ordered that
number to be increased to 1.15 million
analysts say 190 000 troops took part in
moscow's initial Invasion including
russian-backed militias and security
forces already in donbass in eastern
Ukraine the defense minister has said
about 6 000 soldiers have died so far
U.S officials though put that figure
much higher at between 60 and 80 000.
let's bring in Pavel valgenhauer who is
a defense and Military analyst and joins
us via Skype from Moscow Pavel thanks so
much for being on this NewsHour in some
areas of the occupied regions of Ukraine
has about a three to one Manpower
Advantage is 300 000 troops enough to
help Moscow recoup some of the losses on
the ground in Ukraine
well it might be more
this is most likely the initial number
but that's as much as the Russian
military can actually integrate arm and
train and equip in the coming months
uh and this will not be we haven't much
of an effect uh before winter when the
winter campaign begins somewhere uh
December New Year because right now the
summer campaign is basically over the
Autumn rains have come they'll turn the
terrain into a sea of what that's
traditional rasputita in Russian which
means that maneuverable Warfare becomes
very tricky though of course both sides
would be showing each other and
continuing to do that so there will be a
pause on the ground and that will give
Russia time to gather reserves for the
winter when the frost comes and the dirt
turns into concrete and you can move
through fields and dirt roads again with
tanks and other equipment so that's when
the real big fight is going to be and
where these reserves are really intended
to be used so Pablo you're saying that
the time frame that that we can expect
these three hundred thousand troops to
hit the ground is likely to be winter
then so has this been in the works for
some time do you think or will these
troops need training and the like
uh well there was clear that the Russian
operation is in crisis they have serious
problems with the equipment and with
reserves so yes they needed to make some
kind of either change their strategy so
they changed their strategy to follow on
and come in a stronger when the winter
campaign begins and most likely hoping
that that will could bring a decisive
change on the battlefield but we of
course have to see when that really
happens how effective this mobilization
is going to be there will be problems
with equipping these soldiers and new
soldiers and actually to find good
tactical commanders for them well we
appreciate your insights as always
Pebble falgenhauer a defense and
Military analyst from Moscow thank you